en tunisie comme de partout dans le
monde la population doit faire face aux
coronavirus alors que ici dans les
grandes villes le nombre de contaminés
ne cesse de grandir dans les campagnes
et les montagnes la population semble
moins affecté par ce virus comme ici à
testour la population n'a pas changé ses
habitudes manque de communication manque
de prévention
les autorités tentent d'alerter elle la
population mais beaucoup de villageois
continuent de vivre normalement comme
chaque jour c'est le même rituel pour
achat après avoir récolté ses céréales
elle va les faire cuire en préparer une
pâte pour nourrir toute sa famille ici à
la campagne la vie suit son cours loin
de l'épidémie du cornât virus malgré les
campagnes de prévention du gouvernement
et de la municipalité
les populations elles se sentent
complètement exclue de cette épidémie
pour eux c'est un fléau qui touche que
les grandes villes on ne veut pas trop
en entendre parler car nous vivons loin
de tout et en plein air nous avons une
vie simple et se corona nous ne l'avons
pas en tête
j'espère juste que ça restera loin de
nous et qu'on n'entendra pas trop parler
de toute façon nous nous en remettons à
dieu
depuis la fermeture des écoles les
enfants des zones rurales s'occupent
comme ils peuvent jouer avec le bétail
ou les animaux domestiques occupe la
quasi totalité de leur journée le
coronavirus ils en ont une idée assez
vagues un manque d'instruction et un
manque de communication dans ces zones
pourraient expliquer cette ignorance
bien sûr je sais que c'est un virus qui
traînent toi mohamed tu as peur du
corona bon moi je n'ai pas peur c'est
juste une petite balle est dit ici les
gens n'ont pas peur la peur par ici nous
vivons loin la campagne on n'a pas peur
de ce virus car il ne vient pas
jusqu'ici
est ce qu'on vous a expliqué qu'il était
important de porter des masques et
d'utiliser du gel oui mais je vois que
personne n'en porte par ici parce que
les gens n'ont pas peur ici parce que le
virus ne vient pas chez nous il ya
beaucoup de personnes qui ont été
contaminées comme en chine ou encore en
france si gens là doivent porter des
masques et des gants
se protéger dans le village de testour
comme dans beaucoup de villages en
tunisie il est difficile pour les
autorités locales de faire appliquer le
confinement et les règles sanitaires
malgré la multiplication des campagnes
de prévention
le message semble avoir du mal à passer
auprès des populations
un casse tête pour le maire de cette
commune qui tente tant bien que mal de
protéger sa population contre cette
pandémie qui pourrait être fatal pour
les régions d'oural le seul maire est ce
que vous pouvez nous expliquer comment
vivent les gens ici à testour alors de
ce corner ben écoute et voilà les gens
vivent presque normalement
j'ai l'impression que malgré de tout ce
qu'on fait comme sensibilisation par
rapport aux citoyens ils se sentent pas
concernés par ce phénomène da et ils
disent bon de toute façon si un
phénomène qui arrive qu aux autres
qu'ils n'arrivent pas à nous il ya eu
des ddd suspicion de cas qui
heureusement pour nous était négatif
mais croyez moi j'ai très très peur
qu'il arrive un cas positif
si par malheur il nous arrive une
pandémie à testour je crois que ça sera
vraiment chaotique
parce que vous savez comme tout le monde
que la tunisie n'a pas énormément de
moyens on n'a pas l'infrastructure
combien en europe et ailleurs pour faire
face à ce fléau à testour comme de
nombreuses villes dans les montagnes et
les campagnes tunisienne aucun cas de
contamination n'a été enregistré mais le
risque zéro n'existe pas la raison pour
laquelle les autorités continuent de
prévenir la population et de faire
respecter le confinement malgré cela les
gens continuent de vivre normalement
le gouvernement craint qu'une épidémie
dans ces zones rurales puissent être un
scénario catastrophique pour la tunisie